en el vídeo anterior vimos la curva de
valoración para la titulación de un
ácido fuerte
hcl con una base fuerte en eeuu
y encontramos el ph antes de agregar la
base es decir en este punto también
encontramos el ph después de agregar 10
mililitros de la base que corresponde a
este punto este fue el inciso a y este
fue el inciso b ahora vamos con el
inciso c cuál es el ph después de
agregar 20 mililitros de una solución
0.500 molar de hidróxido de sodio
entonces cuántos moles de iones
hidróxido agregamos bueno como la
concentración de hidróxido de sodio es
0.500 molar esta es también la
concentración de iones hidróxido porque
tenemos una base fuerte así que la
concentración de iones y drogas
en solución es 0.500 molar y recordemos
que la polaridad es igual a los moles
sobre los litros así que esto es igual a
moles / litros cuántos litros tenemos
bueno si agregamos 20 mililitros 20
mililitros movemos nuestro punto decimal
123 lugares y nos quedan 0.02 litros
entonces para calcular los moles
simplemente multiplicamos 0.5 x 0.02 y
esto es igual a 0.01 moles de iones
hidróxido agregados a la solución ácida
inicial
en el vídeo anterior calculamos los
moles de iones sidronio en la solución
que son 0.0100 moles de h3 o más y tiene
sentido porque observen que en el ácido
y la base tenemos los mismos datos
aquí tenemos 20 mililitros y aquí
también acá tenemos una concentración
0.500 molar y aquí también es el mismo
cálculo para obtener los moles de h3 o
más que también se puede escribir como h
más entonces tenemos el mismo número de
moles del ácido y de la base y recuerden
que la base que agregamos neutraliza
completamente al ácido presente así que
los iones sidronio h3o más son
neutralizados por la base que agregamos
y si h3o más dona un protón al h menos
h2o y como el h3 o más dona un protón
nos queda otra molécula de h2o así que
se forman dos moléculas de h2o ahora
empezamos con 0.01 moles de o h menos
0.01 moles de la base y tenemos los
mismos moles del ácido 0.01 moles de
ácido entonces como tenemos suficiente
base para neutralizar completamente al
ácido esta es una reacción 1 a 1 molar
toda la base reaccionará para
neutralizar todo el ácido y cuando eso
ocurre el ph es igual al ph del agua que
como sabemos es igual a 7
7.00 también podíamos escribir la
reacción como hcl más n
que producen h2o porque además yo h
menos formen h2o y también se forma en
ea cl
entonces si el ácido y la base se
neutralizan sólo nos queda la solución
acuosa de cloruro de sodio por eso el ph
es igual al ph del agua ya que los iones
de sodio y los anones cloruro no afectan
el ph entonces el ph después de agregar
20 mililitros de la base es igual a 7
vamos a localizar este punto en nuestra
curva de titulación que también se le
conoce como curva de valoración al
agregar 20 mililitros de la base
h debe ser igual a 7 entonces el punto
que hemos encontrado es el punto de
equivalencia este es el punto de
equivalencia
agregamos suficientes moles de la base
para neutralizar completamente el ácido
presente y así alcanzamos el punto de
equivalencia
finalmente en el inciso t nos piden
encontrar el ph después de agregar 20.2
mililitros de una solución 0.500 molar
de hidróxido de sodio entonces primero
calculemos los moles de iones hidróxido
que agregamos sabemos que la
concentración de iones hidróxido es
0.500 molar y sabemos que la polaridad
es igual a los moles sobre los litros
entonces queremos encontrar los moles y
cuántos litros agregamos bueno 20 puntos
20 mililitros es igual a 0.02 0 20
litros
entonces usemos la calculadora tenemos
0.5 por 0.0200 es igual a 0.0 101
tenemos 0.0 101 moles de iones hidróxido
ahora como los iones hidróxido
reaccionen con los iones hidronew ya
vimos que nuestra reacción es h 3 o más
más o menos que producen 2 h2o y esta
vez tenemos 0.010 un moles de iones
hidróxido 0.01 01 y empezamos con 0.01
moles de iones y drones 0.01 como esta
vez agregamos más moles de la base todo
el ácido es neutralizado neutralizamos
todo el ácido y la mayor parte de la
base reacción perdemos 0
punto 0 100 moles de la base y nos
quedan 0.0001 moles de base entonces
todo el ácido es neutralizado y nos
queda una pequeña cantidad de la base
ahora veamos cuál es el volumen total
empezamos con 20 mililitros de la
solución ácida y en este punto de la
titulación agregamos 20.2 mililitros más
agregamos 20 puntos 2 mililitros esto es
igual a 40 puntos 20 mililitros entonces
cuál es la concentración de iones
hidróxido bueno moles / litros
tenemos 0.0001 moles de hidróxido y el
volumen lo tenemos en mililitros pero es
igual a 0.04 0 2
litros usemos la calculadora 0.0001
entre 0.0 40 20 esto es igual a 0.002 la
concentración de iones hidróxido es
igual a 0.002 molar y nuestro objetivo
es encontrar el ph pero primero vamos a
calcular el p
h el p h es igual a menos el logaritmo
de la concentración de iones hidróxido
esto es igual a menos el logaritmo de
0.002 entonces menos logaritmo de 0.002
el p
h es igual a 2.7 el t
h es igual a 2.7 y finalmente para
encontrar el ph sabemos qué
o h es igual a 14 si sustituimos este
valor el ph es igual a 14 menos 2.7 que
es igual a 11.3
este es el ph vamos a localizarlo en
nuestra curva de titulación agregamos
20.2 mililitros de la base y encontramos
que el ph es igual a 11.3 entonces como
estamos cerca de los 20 mililitros y el
ph es igual a 11.3 este es nuestro punto